is not the law the law is that you're
supposed to go through this process
where they vet you and they find off
you're a criminal and they find out if
you're a terrorist and yeah they're not
doing that at all they're just opening
the border and they're essentially
buying votes yeah they're they're doing
this they're they're letting these
people come in and they're assuming
these people are going to vote for the
Democrats Elon was telling me that when
you go there you really understand the
scope of it he goes it's extraordinary
and I don't I don't blame them at all
man if you're just a regular person that
was unfortunate to be born in a terrible
environment and you realize if I can get
to America I can feed my family yeah I
get
it yeah if I was in Guatemala 100% I'd
have a backpack at this point I think
you call him disaffected liberal as far
as I know he didn't even vote last time
the question is what America First
candidate can actually get some of those
people all of the people who have since
October 7th have woken up to what
identity politics have done the big
issue here is who can beat Joe Biden